皆さん今月は肇社長です以前僕のサブチャンネルの方で
+オブキングスのテレビ cv にちなんだドッキリを仕掛けるということで視聴者
さんの方に参加の募集をかけたのですがその時
ドッキリを仕掛けるターゲットの方がすごい大物タレントさんという話をしました
その大物た人とはだ
ねえかな
ボイスとねー
class of kings とゲームですね兵士を使って白
祝儀尿素ゲームなんですけどもどうもでとミックさんと顎の部分が白に見えてしまい
ましてちょっと就役したくなってしまいました
今回はコミックさんの顎を白に見立てて実際のゲームのように治療に襲撃してみたいと
思いますって言って今 by ですねゲームをダウンロードしてくれた方の中から15
に優秀の兵士をこちらから選抜させていただきました
本当にたくさんの方のご応募本当にありがとうございますこの私ロードぼくん捕まりに
来るんですけどもそれは寝静まった瞬間に僕以外の15に名刺が服について知ろう囲ん
で一斉に士郎
襲撃していると思いますウッドミックさんのアゴにやしろと言ってもやっぱりあ語なの
でわかりやすいようにた年
シールを貼りまして襲撃していこうと思います確実にするをぶつけるべきで愛子
本日は
お集まりいただき誠にありがとうございます今回の企画は僕の家に一つのお城が眠って
おりましてその後ろをみんなで襲撃しようという企画でございます
大物ゲストの誰かにドッキリずっという企画だったと思うんですけども
リストの方がなんと
トミックスサンドバー
フェルトビッグ3を朝いずみんぐでしようというドッキリでございます
ああああああ
かっこいいん
4を
おおおおおおおおおおおお
あっはっは
ん
持っています
おっ
あっ運ぶ不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不
不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不
none
wh
んだ
ん
私の作った
上
うっ
うううういい
あっ
グーン
続よく寝ててください
と以前まだ組めずと見ちゃだめですよ
またてくださいねうーん
をカバーし
おっ
うんえっ
わからん
士郎襲撃してきましたん
voodoo いうのはですね
響く7を強く見かけて撃っ
対応弊社管理するかというかウドこれそれぞれ
ドッキリ入れこれは
僕クードゥ
入って夕食の毒気で終了いたしましたお疲れ様でしたーー
酷いんだけど疎通とミックさんのアゴにしろーはっとところでちょっと気づかれて
一見ちょっと失敗っぽくなっちゃったんですけども
まだまだでしたちょっとみなさんに聞いてみましょう
どうでしたか悔しかっ者数気付かれたんですけどもダメ出る
寝かせてプリウス嘆いたのでまぁそこは良かったと思います
どうでしたが面白かった妄想食べる外から声聞こえた時に警視正しろーっ
これほど大変なことだっは
ていました class of king 簡単に四郎を落とせるのでぜひ皆さん遊ん
でみてくださいという意味で暮らすはドキンです皆さんもプレイしましたでしょうか
このゲームは全世界で抽選万ダウンロードを突破した白育成シミュレーション rpg
でございますキングとなって自分の城や閉所教科書世界人のキングたちとリアルタイム
でシュミレーションバトルを楽しむことが出来ます同盟を組んだ
他国を攻めようとして最強の帝国を作りましょうぜひで本当に面白いのでぜひ皆さんし
たからダウンロードできますのでプレイし遊んでみてください
じゃあ